c'est le plus beau coup un humain c'est
un joyau qu'il faut préserver bien sûr
mais c'est le plus beau coin du mois on
a la mer le soleil la colline on a des
copains déboulant sa nuit c'est le plus
beau coup un mouvement
déjà nous gêne pas c'est les voitures
qui nous gêne parce qu'il est il
maintenant je sais pas la voiture a le
même mais c'est le nombre de voitures
qui nous mettent en danger la règle
c'est l'interdiction de circulation par
mesure de sécurité
c'est pour laisser passer les voitures
de pompiers et de ce qu est le police ce
qui est embêtant c'est gérable par
exemple qui se met au milieu de la route
ça c'est un méta ça on ne peut pas
passer après vous avez des gens avec des
gros 4 4 e mentent sur la colline
directement sur l'espace à protéger là
ça va mais vous imaginez le week-end par
exemple kenya par la fermeture
les jeunes se mettent au milieu de la
chaussée c'est à dire qui ajuste une
voiture qui passe d'une autre une autre
inquiétude pour les véhicules de
pompiers il ya eu trois à trois bagarres
entre automobilistes parce que les jurés
des jeunes sont battus dans une bagarre
il ya eu un blessé
le blessé atelier contient des pompiers
n'ont pas pu venir
vous avez vraiment est un peu peut-être
gens ça glisse énormément
voyez les pierres comme le sont pour des
voiliers ça c'est l'érosion de lui-même
quoi les jeunes qui passent
c'est dangereux parce que ça glisse
savez les gens qui prennent le chemin
certains sont équipés même vous
commencez à comme nous l'a masquée
seulement puis d'autres où vous aimeriez
passer il arrive il en est on
ils partent avec des tons là c'est
dangereux
ces vieux pêcheur qui sont obligés de
passer chez tout le monde petit 40 est
en deuil
j'ai vu transiter par le monde plus de
30 bateaux ce qui fait beaucoup ne se
rend pas compte parce que c'est pas la
route c'est pas les 1500 voitures de sur
tout mais trente bateaux qui circulent
avec la moitié qui connaissent pas pour
les règles de navigation pour se croiser
dans sa phase en travers c'est compliqué
pour être vraiment très très attentif
[Musique]
moi ça m'a fait sourire parce que
lorsqu'on dit n'allez pas dans les
calanques parce que l'eau est froide
c'est pas du marketing ce n'est pas de
la rigolade quoi nous les gens ici
principalement ce sont des marseillais
qui viennent donc vous pouvez leur dire
ce que vous les connaissez très bien le
coin ils savent très bien connaissait
des sentiers savent où ils veulent quoi
[Musique]
permet l'accès je suis pas trop d'accord
je trouve comme paye déjà pas mal de
choses payer un espace de liberté moi je
à titre perso je ne suis pas d'accord
quand on tire on va dire qu'on sera bien
obligé de camp des jeunes on pourra pas
faire autrement on sera bien obligé de
dire tel calanques qui a atteint de tant
de personnes feraient leur entrée
on partage on oui mais pas trop demander
non plus pas une sur fréquentation
alors là humaine humaine